[Musique]
oui produit des effets on l'a vu en
chine il ya des effets ils ont une
diminution réelle du nombre de cas alors
qu'ils étaient en situation est
extrêmement inquiétante
ils ont eu des effets au bout d'un mois
et demi un mois et un mois et demie de
confinement
en fait personne ne sait on tâtonne tout
le monde tâtonne tant qu'il ya des gens
qui vous à ceux qui vous assure que ça
va durer trois semaines un mois et demi
ce sont des hypothèses
on peut penser enfin j'aime bien qu'un
jour ça sera propre et évidemment
insuffisant peut-être qu'un mois ou un
mois et demi c'est plus raisonnable
[Musique]
la durée d'incubation c'est-à-dire le
moment où vous rencontrez le virus ou
milles entre de votre corps et vous
allez commencer à être malade c'est à
dire présentait des signes quand vous
êtes malade vous avez bien compris ça
varie de deux à douze très chaud ça
c'est la première partie de la maladie
vous ne savez pas que vous êtes malade à
ce que le virus est dans votre organisme
et commence à faire son petit travail de
sape au bout de deux à douze jours
moyenne 4,5 jours vous tous vous êtes
malade vous mettez à tous et a craché
parfois des difficultés respiratoires et
puis parfois des choses plus graves
heureusement beaucoup plus rares
médecins versailles eh ben ça ça va
durer à peu près deux semaines
à peu près de spa et puis au bout de
deux semaines le virus sera probablement
disparu mais comme on ne fait plus de
tests pour savoir si il a disparu pas je
ne sais pas bien vous répondons qu'il
faut compter c'est à dire trois semaines
au total 3 4 semaines au total puisque
si vous avez une incubation de 12 jours
est une maladie effective de 14
ça vous fait un mois
dans l'air il y a quelques arguments des
gens qui pensent qu'il peut y avoir ce
qu'on appelle une aérosols isation du
virus peut se balader donc de
l'importance chez vous d'ailleurs et les
pièces il faut aérer le cas et c'est
pour ça et c'est une des raisons qui
fait que le risque de contamination est
particulièrement grand quand vous êtes
plusieurs dans une pièce fermée
c'est d'ailleurs là qu'on a vu les taux
de contamination les plus importants
quand vous vous concentrez sur les
situations de zone clause saverdun des
pièces églises des réunions de famille
on a des taux d' attaques qui sont
jusqu'à 35 % c'est-à-dire vous déjeunez
vous dînez avec vos copains vous êtes
dans une salle fermée et bien une
personne malade même s'il ne sais pas
peut contaminer 35% delà de la pièce
réussir il meurt pas tout de suite
combien de temps ça c'est une querelle
de virologues j'entrerai pas dedans et
il n'est pas impossible que le virus
pendant plusieurs heures restent sur la
table sur laquelle vous avez posé vos
grosses mains sales de patients affectés
pour ça qu'il faut sauver les mêmes sans
arrêt
c'est toujours dit à x 4 cordes à dieuze
en réalité c'est un chiffre qui est
purement indicatif mais qui est faux
c'est la partie émergée de l'iceberg
parce que pour deux raisons d'abord on
teste pas tout le monde et la deuxième
raison c'est que la moitié des patients
sont asymptomatiques
entre 1 et 3% mais ça ne veut pas dire
grand chose parce qu'un taux de
mortalité sa longue de mort elle
identifie bien là c'est facile
/ à l'angle de cartes mais comme je
voulais expliquer tout à l'heure le vrai
nombre de cas on ne connaît pas
il est vrai qu'on a du talent il va y
avoir des patients jeunes qui vont de 20
ans qui vont devoir développer des
formes graves de réanimation c'est une
certitude
et ça va être ça va rester la minorité
quand même les études chinoises qui
maintenant en trois mois trois mois de
recul quand même un sacré avantage
lorsqu'on apprend devront montre quand
même qu'on est sur une population qui
est plutôt âgés majoritairement très
majoritairement qui a des maladies
associées essentiellement l'hypertension
artérielle le diabète également un peu
les infuse les infecter les infections
respiratoires chroniques loi en fait que
la grippe fonctionnement
mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont des patients
jeunes mais ça va pas être la majorité
simplement
simplement il faut pas penser que les
jeunes sont totalement à l'abri ces
fonds
certains virus qui sont saisonniers
veine viennent de la grippe qu'on a tous
les ans et fan dok tonne début d'hiver
qu'après il disparaît il disparaît à la
fois probablement pour des raisons
météorologiques mais aussi parce que les
gens sortent et sont moins en contact
l'un avec l'autre ils se rencontrent pas
mais en fait on ne sait pas question ce
qui est des virus quand des
saisonnalités a versé par exemple le
virus h1n1 qui est un virus quand on a
beaucoup parlé il ya dix ans lui il est
apparu au printemps
donc on peut l'espérer rien n'est
certain en tout cas ce serait pas très
sérieux de notable est que nature
écoutez le vaccin on l'aura sinon on va
dire
il faudra le produire en plus tout le
monde va en vouloir donc ça va prendre
un peu de temps il faut il faut le
fabriquer a bien entendu parce qu'on
sait jamais virus pour revenir après une
première phase
sortez pas de chez vous limitez vos
interactions sociales ne dormait pas
dans la même chambre que quelqu'un qui
est potentiellement malades
prenez des nouvelles de vos parents et
vos grands parents par téléphone
elle n'est pas les voir pour les
contaminés mais n'essaie pas salle parce
qu'il faudrait pas que cette affaire
fasse qu'on retrouve les gens âgés qui
sont mort tout seul parce que personne
s'en occuper chez eux
aidez nous à ne pas désorganiser le
système c'est à dire que quand vous avez
un petit problème de santé
microscopiques et bien pour une fois
vais pas dire aux urgences
nous entendre et vous allez consulter
votre médecin ou votre pharmacien
demandez conseil à votre infirmière mais
essayé d'épargner des hôpitaux et
services d'urgence et n'écoutez pas les
fausses nouvelles de les véhiculer pas
les fameux fou traitement qui circulent
on revendique tout ça sert à rien soyez
essayé de tenir parce qu'en fait si la
vague arrive
le vrai sujet c'est pas le nombre de
patients entre netapp et ironique envers
on a des ressources
c'est le nombre de patients en même
temps comprenez que si par exemple nous
sommes à l'hôpital pompidou là ce matin
pendant l'heure qui vient j'ai 100
personnes car ils vont être submergé en
revanche si ces 100 personnes arrivent
répartis sur deux mois et bien moi je
serai les prendre en charge sereinement
et parfaitement d'heure dans tout le
sujet il est là il faut étaler la vague
[Musique]